hi I'm Keith Bryan I'm math professor at
the University of Iowa I'm going to talk
tomorrow about a new book that's
available from the Wolfram store called
advanced calculus using Mathematica it's
all written in Mathematica notebooks and
we've been using variations on it for
many years in engineering math
over the last 15 years I've turn around
6000 engineering students this material
and use these the materials I'm going to
talk about in various formats this this
current one we finally published as an
e-book I guess you call it in
Mathematica notebooks and that's
specifically what I'll talk about
calculus really is a subject that's
worth the engineering students time to
study it's a basis of a lot of their
engineering courses and it really has
served us the language of change for the
last 300 years but it's still important
and I can give you a particular example
of a few years ago I was duck hunting in
North Dakota with a friend of mine there
weren't any ducks so we got talking
about his research on human visual depth
perception and the result of that was a
little bit of calculus and a little bit
of vision science and we solved an
important problem that had appeared that
appeared in nature in 2008 about how
people perceive depth from motion so
calculus is alive and well and well
worth the students time at the same time
okay so the book i'm going to tell you
about i want to tell you about how its
organized and specifically with a goal
of trying to make the subject more
accessible to students Mathematica plays
a role in that it kind of two levels one
it could help students understand the
concepts and really have a good
conceptual understanding not necessarily
pedantic rigor Epsilon's and Delta's but
a good idea of what the gradient
measures and things like that is really
important for engineers they're going to
use this subject but ok I thought of
really a dual audience for today's talk
because I want to spend a little bit of
time talking about how
we distribute this stuff it's reasonably
important that you're able to get the
stuff out without giving it all away I
guess over the years and while I
developed this I used to sell versions
of this and CD a local bookstore and
students would steal it with impunity I
sold it for five bucks I mean this with
this store charge the theft didn't
bother me but what really annoyed me was
when they came to my office to have me
fix the stolen copy that didn't work
because they didn't know how to so we've
worked out a pretty good system that
wolfram to distribute this stuff okay so
that kind of how the book works and how
Mathematica helps hopefully helps
engineers both learn the subject and
expand their the power of the things
that they can use they use calculus for
okay so let's go on to so this is kind
of an outline give you an idea what the
contents are what the organization is
some of the organizational themes you
know how we how I organize the material
and a little bit of stuff that
Mathematica is making possible that's
kind of fallen out of traditional
calculus books we teach this core I
teach the course and sort of two levels
this is the table of contents this is a
you know the Wolfram thing this is the
actual I guess I won't enlarge this this
is an Aggie I an actual page from the
book with all these links and the
picture has to do with divergence
theorem and and curl and all these
things are sort of hotlinked into the
actual text okay the table of contents
this looks pretty ordinary except for
some of the advanced topics that have
kind of
lost and I'll mention a few some things
okay so one of the mathematical things
how did they organize that so this is
the part of the talk for people that
might be interested in actually using
this to teach multivariable calculus
vector calculus can be hard subject for
students to learn if especially if they
approach it from the point of view of
well memorize a formula for this case
memorize a formula for that case let me
give you an example the gradients
perpendicular to the graph right
well in some cases yes in other cases
now so the equation of the tangent sort
of there's sort of all these different
versions of the equation for the tangent
and why they all involve partial
derivatives of some sort why is that
well there's a way to organize the
materials that there's one way to
calculate the tangent but it involves
thinking about how you represent graphs
so this is kind of an organizational
thing for the whole course graphs are
organized as explicit implicit or
parametric graphs and if you do that
then there's really only one way to
calculate the tangent and it's
compatible with the main idea of
differential calculus that smooth things
under a microscope
look linear and so that's kind of the
idea and let's see I want to do that
next what I've done for this talk
because you can access access this later
as I put two kinds of links in here one
directly to the web so this is this is a
web page and it goes through these
different kind of things so if you
organize calculus this way implicit
explicit parametric graphs then there's
really one procedure for finding
tangents but it has various
implementations Z equals f of X and Y
and this is the procedure in that case
as a web page it's always three steps
calculate the total differential specify
the point of tangency
and interpret the graph of either local
or global coordinates so this is the
explicit case this is the implicit case
in two dimensions and you should sort of
ignore the fact that the prints small
and observe that it looks like the same
procedure in every case and it is except
that this procedure results in a linear
equation of the same type and so the
next step is to understand the linear
algebra for the different cases of
explicit implicit in parametric graphs
okay so that's that's a theme to try to
help the students learn the subject now
let's see here what kind of a okay I've
also put links directly to the text for
the talk because I wasn't sure I'd have
internet connectivity today so one way
an ethe matica helps a lot and Eric is
here he's done a lot of really nice
stuff on the web one way it helps is it
just gives people a sort of dynamic or
interactive kinds of graphics here's
here's one particular example in
calculus of several variables it's
important to be able to deal with either
explicit or implicit graphs and contour
graphs are a little bit hard to
understand if you've ever hiked with a
topo map I'm only alive because I didn't
do it in the fog when I got to a place
that looked kind of steep I got the map
out and noticed that the lines were
close together and didn't step off the
cliff but here's an example of an
interactive program and remember this
first main idea of differential calculus
is if you zoom in it looks linear and
here we can zoom in and see both you
listed graph and The Associated contour
plot so let's see if this whole
work so this is from the text and it's
it's zooming in on the illicit graph and
there's lots of controls all over the
place now those procedures that I told
you about it's really one procedure but
for three different kinds of graphs or
in different dimensions there are in
effect a way to compute what you'd see
if you could if you had an infinitely
powerful microscope so there's the
microscope that goes with it but there's
also the computational procedure for the
students okay so what aspect of the you
know the book is to have these
interactive kinds of graphical programs
actually I thought I was going to say
something else at the same I hope it
comes up later if it doesn't all
remember okay I want to show you what
the book looks like as a lot of it looks
fairly conventional but this will come
up later another theme in this course
that we teach and we revamp the
engineering math program about 15 years
ago when I started teaching these huge
classes to put multi variable topics
sooner in the curriculum the
old-fashioned curriculum essentially was
students to calc 1 calc 2 the old Thomas
of course from 1948 and then they took
minier algebra and differential
equations and finally they took vector
calculus but in the meantime they'd
studied physics dynamic statics and
thermodynamics and used multivariable
calculus in all of those courses and we
decided that's a little silly we should
teach the multivariable calculus sooner
and it's worked pretty well with physics
the students that take this kind of on
schedule get a heavy dose of vectors in
their second semester so all of course
is sort of organized in this way and one
of the things that I encourage students
to do is build a lexicon not a lexicon
between
say German and English but a lexicon
between geometry and algebra and then
build on this throughout the course and
one particular example of this this is
an exercise set from the course and
these are all links back into the text
to help help them remember what should
be in their lexicon my students are
supposed to carry a little notebook
that'll fit in their pocket or purse or
whatever and I told them that the math
police can stop them on the sidewalk and
demand their lexicon and the idea is
that then they can do this so this is a
kind of a neat problem if velocity is
equal to acceleration across position
just by basic geometry you can show that
this is motion on a latitude line and at
constant speed and this just involves
using the geometric lexicon over and
over so we try to carry this theme
throughout the course you know the
professional mathematician I guess no
surprise that vectors play an important
role but we're just sort of systematic
about it the other thing that the course
doesn't do everything in the standard
order so for example most books that
multivariable calculus when they first
talk about partial derivatives talk
about the vector chain rule vector
product rule but if you examine the
exercises you find that there are no
exercises that can't be done without
those rules that's really bad form
itself because students usually working
with formulas described in high school
terms and those can be solved with the
calc 1 rules by just holding one
variable at time constant so what's the
role of that abstract product rule
unchanged why are they important do we
really need them later in the course
okay I guess I slipped I said the
abstract rules what's important about
those rules is when there
plot in an abstract way so for example
the curvature vector is perpendicular to
the tent to the curve and that's a
consequence believe it or not of the dot
product rule and here it is in the text
whoops if I can see the mouse here it is
so there's a theorem and the way you
prove it as you say the unit tangent has
norm one so the dot product is a
constant differentiate both sides and
you get acceleration dot tangent equals
zero which is perpendicular by the
product rule now what's a little upset
interestings at this level as what's
important is the general rule not
specific applications with formulas so
when we review differentiation a little
bit in the beginning of the course when
we do partial derivatives and we use
partial derivatives a lot before we get
to this particular topic we try to get
them to write the product rule of the
chain rule rather than to just say it in
words why well because when they get to
this level writing the product rule for
vectors and the chain rule and so forth
is what's important okay conservation of
energy comes from the chain rule the
fact that planets orbit in a plane is
the product rule for the cross product
and so that and these are general rules
not for a given formula okay I'm running
low on time let me switch over to how
does computer work how what kind of
computer work the students do okay I
wanted to show you and this is where I
wanted to show you what the textbook
looks like so this is probably too
little I let me make this bigger so this
is the way the textbook looks and of
course
bigger and the point of this is it looks
pretty much like a conventional textbook
but of course pictures like this a hot
linked to an interactive program so a
lot of what students do is you know read
this material and solve problems solve
exercises so there's there was a
procedure here for finding the tangent
plane and so forth but we do do some
computation and not really a lot about
once a week we have a computer exercise
and they kind of vary from basic things
where we show them how you implement a
computer how you implement on the
computer something they've solved by
hand so this is sort of get them started
programming so they learn how to
calculate the equation of a tangent
plane and then a little later they learn
how to make that into a program that
draws a tangent point computes it with
Mathematica and draws it things like
that we sort of help them through get
them started with basic kind of
programming by the way in the course we
felt it was important not that they just
see things but that they actually do
some of the computing themselves we're
trying to get them to transition into
professional engineers being able to use
Mathematica as a tool
later on we once they've built up some
basic programming tools we asked them a
bunch of conceptual kind of problems and
this is an example that's kind of a
dirty trick draw a surface and it's
tangent plane and that they've had help
to do before they're supposed to use the
work there and then draw the tangent
vector that points uphill as fast as
possible well this is kind of a trick to
see if they understand concepts about
the gradient vector one of the things
that I've found experimentally is most
students know the gradient points in the
direction of fastest increase
but they don't know the gradient the
norm of the gradient has meaning and we
fussed a lot trying to explain vector
sir quantities with both magnitude and
direction
well this exercise requires them to
figure out what's the magnitude do to
help solve this problem so there are
problems like this again they're kind of
conceptual mathematics there are tricks
with computing the other one that let's
see here if I've got this the other
trick to get students to learn a little
Mathematica programming cuz they fuss
that oh oh I don't know how to program
well I mean some of it is so obvious
that you don't need to learn how to
program you just sort of learn how to
get that right curly Q's on things and
lots and lots of exercises in the text
that are intended to be solved by paper
and pencil have solutions that are
written in Mathematica code and if they
want to check their answer they have to
at least press ENTER and and see if
they've done it right so there's a
little bit of incentive to get them
using Mathematica a tool of their own
okay let's see here time is really
running low now I wanted to advertise
okay so computing work is some basically
things to help them start programming
some real simple calculations to check
paper and pencil work and there's some
conceptual problems where they're
supposed to kind of put things together
and solve a bigger problem and there are
a lot of examples but that was just one
of them
it's kind of hard to summarize 300
megabytes of text in 25 minutes in 24
minutes 23 22 he's got his numbers up
there is showing me in the back some of
the things that I've put in the book
that have fallen out of the curriculum
and falling out of most of the standard
textbooks I call novel topics but
they're often not new
they're the things that were known so
for example something that's often
handled incorrectly in and calculus is
these formulas from thermodynamics and
let me make this bigger this expression
partial U with respect to PV held
constant most a lot of math books treat
that as well.you as a function of P and
V and when you differentiate with
respect to P the other variables
constant that's not what this means at
all and you'll find it that that way in
many books what this means is use a
function of P V and T you want the
derivative of how much u changes when P
varies V is held constant but the
equation of state is maintained PV
equals NRT and so this is a topic that's
kind of missing and lots of books and
actually incorrect and quite a number
how much does Mathematica help this I
don't know a lot but the point is the
different constraint differentiation
problem gets a little bit technical
Mathematica help some and Mathematica
also of course can give lots of specific
examples functional dependence or vector
to I don't know even know what the
functional dependence is but it's sort
of the case of implicit function theorem
when the standard it conditions not that
and that's that plays an important role
in problems like for example vector
potential vector potential is if you
have a vector field is great whose
divergence is zero can you find another
vector field whose curl gives you that
original thing that's mentioned in most
of the books but was never proved and
there's a simple formula for that and
it's in the book it's it's okay it's
only local so there's a mathematical
computation for it oh I said simple it's
maybe not so simple it involves you know
three integrals but handling
the right order so it's the kind of
thing that it's nice to be able to use
Mathematica organize the calculation and
do it once and for all
okay there there are others like if you
have a flow of a two-dimensional vector
field and you zoom in on a an
equilibrium point well the general
principle says it should look like the
linear thing and there's a theorem here
that says it does and examples where you
can zoom in and look at it now this for
example is a way to show how to
linearize the pendulum the pendulums and
on linear equation and zooming in on the
equilibrium gives you the standard
linearized pendulum so that's in there
okay you can take a look at the website
for this and the website looks a lot
like the book because it was produced
from Mathematica notebooks but it's not
it's not doesn't have full interactive
implementation actually I thought of
trying to do the book that way that I
finally decided it's important for
engineering students to learn to do a
little bit of Mathematica let me just
talk about the last minute or two that I
have about how this gets distributed so
this is available from the Wolfram store
if you go to the website I've got a
button that'll send you there we sell
this for $49 that means the students we
have a site license for Mathematica but
if students don't have the site license
that will costs under a hundred just
barely and and if you're interested in
distributing these things and not giving
them away free and then fixing them in
your office what we've done is the folks
that WRI made a CDF installer so they
download the students download this
collection of 600 and whatever it is
notebooks and
then they run a little cdf program and
from the cloud the cdf program
authenticates that there the purchaser
and installs style sheets and and
utilities packages in hidden directories
in their program and the sign then the
back says stop so i won't tell you more
about the details but basically that's a
way to sell the book to a single user
and not put it on the web